the relief of finally being listened to
these families have fought for years to
prove their babies shouldn't have died
it's a moment of um
it's a sweet sadness it should never
have befallen um grieving
bereaved parents to uncover the biggest
scandal tragedy in nhs history
yeah it's been for kate
she never got a chance to live she never
got a chance for life
and
she was so loved
and it's all i could do for her i
couldn't even be there when she died so
this is all i could do for her
kate's death and so many others caused
by mistakes their parents listened as
the damning verdict was delivered
we now know that this is a trust that
failed to investigate
failed to learn and failed to improve
this resulted in tragedies and
life-changing incidents for so many of
our families
sophia hotchkiss died in 2014.
her mother now has blake
[Music]
but last year she thought she might lose
him too
so i went in with blake when i was in i
was in pain
um his movements were reducing
and
a consultant was saying to me that they
need to weigh up the pros and cons of
delivering them
and
i said to them
i've already buried a child because of
you i can't do this again you're not
killing another one of my children
the report details why so many died in
the two decades up to 2019
but families who lost babies more
recently than that have now been
contacting the investigation team
staff have also come forward to share
ongoing concerns
the hospital chief executive sticking to
her script i believe our services are
safe
we have invested heavily in staffing and
we've brought about significant change
but babies are still dying aren't they
i i believe our services are safe but
jacob harris died in 2018. by then the
trust was already under investigation
that overwhelming
sort of sense of loss
will never go away
he was stillborn his mother's concerns
ignored his parents angry that by then
lessons hadn't been learnt
constantly having that question of what
if
what if they'd listen to people 15 20 30
years ago
he's not here there's always this little
shadow of this little boy that should
should be there
they are the babies who'll always be
missing
and always be missed
becky johnson sky news shrewsbury